ah
the Liar's punishment is that even when
he speaks the truth No One Believes him
life's not as good with money as it is
bad without it
Adam was the first lucky man he had no
mother-in-law
if a problem can be solved with money
then it's not a problem but a cost
God gave man two ears and one mouth so
listen more and talk less
may God protect you from bad people
save yourself from good ones
[Music]
any Jew knows what's better
God cannot be everywhere at once that's
why he created mothers
[Music]
be not sweet or else you'll be eaten be
not bitter or else you'll be spat out
[Music]
fear a goat in front of you a horse
behind you and a fool all around you
a guest and a fish start reeking on the
third day
[Music]
knowledge does not take much space
better a Jew without a beard than a
beard without a Jew
[Music]
man should live at least for curiosity
a deaf man heard a dumb man recount that
a blind man saw a lame man run very fast
[Music]
God protects the poor at least from
expensive sins
if charity costs nothing everyone would
be philanthropists
when an old Maiden marries she becomes a
young wife
[Music]
parents teach their children to talk
children teach their parents silence
all people are good from afar
[Music]
eggs may be cleverer than chickens but
they go rotten too quickly
keeping good silence is harder than
talking good
a bad partner is worse than rain the
latter makes you go home while the
former makes you go outside
foreign
the world will not disappear because
there are many people but because there
are too many non-people
God help me rise to my feet a fall is
what I can do myself
if life doesn't change for the better
wait and it will change for the worse
[Music]
however sweet love may be you can't make
a stew out of it
foreign
Deeds
choosing between two evils a pessimists
picks both
everyone complains about a lack of money
but none complain about a lack of brains
who doesn't have children brings them up
best
[Music]
it's better to die of laughter than of
fear
experience is the word people use to
call their mistakes
being gray of hair means you're simply
old not necessarily wise
[Music]
growing old man's sight worsens but this
allows him to see more
[Music]
act the way you'd like to be and soon
you'll be the way you act
everything we do in life is based on
fear especially love
[Music]
our heads are round so that thought can
change direction
we can endure much more than we think we
can all Human Experience testifies to
that
only a life lived for others is a life
worthwhile
Our Lives no longer belong to us alone
they belong to all those who need us
desperately
[Music]
do not wait until the conditions are
perfect to begin beginning makes the
conditions perfect
a righteous man falls down seven times
and gets up
[Music]
the highest form of wisdom is kindness
do not say something that should never
be heard because ultimately it will be
heard
[Music]
do not separate yourself from the
community
[Music]
act while you can while you have the
chance the means and the strength
the world is a dark place for one who
looks to the table of others
[Music]
we cannot solve our problems with the
same thinking we used when we created
them
a fool is his own Informer
[Music]
a half-truth is a whole lie
[Music]
if God lived on earth people would break
his windows
if not for fear sin would be sweet
if you don't know what you're living for
you haven't yet lived
if you are not a better person tomorrow
than you are today what need have you
for a tomorrow
your own soul is nourished when you are
kind it is destroyed when you are cruel
[Music]
even in this world one can taste the joy
of paradise
[Music]
when a fool is sent to Market all the
merchants are happy
God is a father luck is a stepfather
a person who travels knows a great deal
penis is found in the heart
thank you
he that knows nothing doubts nothing
a mother understands what a child does
not say
sometimes even a liar will speak the
truth
baseless hate is a serious disease
[Music]
a person is lonely until he finds
himself
experiences the mother of wisdom
[Music]
it is not every question that deserves
an answer
jealousy has teeth made of iron
judge every person with the benefit of
the doubt
luck makes you wise luck makes you
wealthy
lend your money and lose your friend
[Music]
a small hole can sink a big ship
he who puts up with insult invites
injury
[Music]
say little and do much
[Music]
because of money the world became ugly
[Music]
money will buy you everything but good
sense
sympathy doesn't provide food
but it makes hunger more endurable
[Music]
who finds a faithful friend finds a
treasure
if a Jew cannot be a Shoemaker he will
dream of being a professor
[Music]
do not accuse a man for no reason when
he has done you no harm
do not plot harm against your neighbor
who lives trustfully near you
[Music]
Pride that dined with vanity suped with
poverty
first mend yourself and then mend others
don't look a gift horse in the mouth
[Music]
when you have no choice mobilize the
Spirit of Courage
lose with truth and right rather than
gain with falsehood and wrong
prepare your proof before you argue
do not be wise in words be wise in Deeds
as he thinks in his heart so he is
[Music]
God is closest to those with broken
hearts
the truth comes out like oil on water
a hint hits harder than the truth
before you utter a word you are the
master
afterwards you are a fool
[Music]
among those who stand Do not sit
two Jews three opinions
[Music]
loose tongues are worse than Wicked
hands
let your ears hear what your mouth says
what the daughter does the mother did
[Music]
don't live in a town where there are no
doctors
[Music]
poverty is no shame but it is no great
honor either
[Music]
what you don't see with your eyes don't
witness with your mouth
[Music]
the only truly dead are those who have
been forgotten
who prays for his neighbor will be heard
for himself
people make plans and God laughs
worries go down better with soup than
without
you only hear three voices in this world
the Babbling of the stream Jewish law
and money
not to have felt pain is not to have
been human
[Music]
sympathy is a little medicine to soothe
the ache in another's heart
only love gives us the taste of Eternity
it is easier to guard a sack full of
fleas than a girl in love
[Music]
against stupidity God himself is
helpless
in a restaurant choose a table near a
waiter
if there is bitterness in the heart
sugar in the mouth won't make life
sweeter
[Music]
a good fellow to everyone is a good
friend to no one
[Music]
do not ask questions of fairy tales
a cheerful heart is good medicine but a
crushed Spirit dries up the bones
ideas are something that usually come
like firemen too late
[Music]
don't sell the sun to buy a candle
[Music]
to make a woman want to have sex with
you the first thing you need to do is
make her feel sexually attracted to you
love is a sweet dream and marriage is
the alarm clock
commit a sin twice and it will not seem
a crime
all things grow with time except grief
[Music]
as you do so will be done to you foreign
[Music]
for wealth
in choosing a friend go up a step
people are like grass in the field some
Blossom some wither
in Jewish history there are no
coincidences
only a life lived for others is a life
worthwhile
there is nothing so whole as a broken
heart
[Music]